when the Sun will rise you will
rub your eyes like a bird you
leave your guiding you across the
sky Ryne the milky way you'll stop
oh darling there you are little fellas crying
when I got home I've got to leave him alone
sometimes remember we have no staff of servants in
this palace ah but we will have I just signed my
engagement with the bending the upper company
oh yeah I beginners understudy and that I've
just been waiting to hear that and how long is
the engagement this time six months in the six
months is an understudy salary six months more
of this cheap lodgings he don't smoke and eating
spaghetti you never seem to consider me or the
kind of life I'm living the country where I can't
speak the language I can't make friends well I
know it's been hard Alice you've been a real sport
but this is the opportunity I've been waiting for
Rosa dinelli's in the company just think what it
means to sing with her I am thinking what do you
mean do you think I'm a fool she asked for you
didn't she why yes of course but to her I'm just
a voice something that sings can make me believe
you're jealous of her you know there's nothing
in the world means anything to me with you when
Billy I've heard that ever since we've been in
Italy well you can stay here and make the most of
this great opportunity I'm going back to America
well now you're talking like a silly child come on
now smile I've got to get back to rehearsal
I just dropped in to tell you the good news
yeah that's that
tonight we'll celebrate we'll go out
for dinner and we won't have spaghetti
give me those papers
there's only one thing to do with you boys take
y'all see the show remember all
the regular work let's be done
well there goes your show I'm sorry boys but the
money for your tickets will have
to be used to replace those dishes
yes the flying trapeze performer gee whiz it
means he sings I like to sing the trained dog
me too but I go too juicy in singing I like
singing he likes it yeah well your mother's
well forget it cuz you're not going to hear
918 what I'll tell you mr. Khanna you'd have
had a bigger house than that if it hadn't been
for some broken dishes right boys you better go
backstage that's Riley so she gets started in
time okay mr. cutter we'll give him a good show
what you think you do that to see the
show well you got a figured all right
the little peek at the lost show and
what do want me to do about it maybe
you could fix it she would like
to hear that sort of thing what
chuckling that is great whether that's
a different way no sets up before
you see everything hey Pasquale great little
stage manager you are my trapeze wasn't set
up again alright that fix it anyway I
never mind I've already done it myself
half empty how am I ever gonna get my back so
you mind keeping your mind on what you're doing
but I've got a good mind and quit this trick
you watching the rest of the philosophically
the next stack I do it you know yeah
oh boy and I did semi-pro ball one
but you don't like my song man oh what
I said well you see me able to show
what you do oh you're not gonna clear huh
and you slip out to see the show yes you
see I'm in the doghouse well he's Nikhil
right back up to the doghouse gonna jump
over the show you crazy no sure but I decided
I'm through with it what you mean you graduated
Oh
come on aah
what you doing with that then I send your home
I didn't go know what you thought you want to
get them in trouble you're not here to my
boat on well you go bad you get here come
on get the hitchhike scoop wait a minute are
you hungry you mean left you've been hiding
the basket all night you connect to some ham
and eggs well nice to steak over hot cake who
was shut up and you're not hungry huh come
on hey cookie fix this bump it up with some
breakfast give him everything he's not hungry
sure anything for a friend of yours Joe then you
see he goes home and this time you know how you
understand English first of all turn number four
I'll just sugar bah
you know I'm in a good voice I don't know Heloise
had it that's all I like you and sing you like
that what all your to do that nobody well you
know get to break your fast and go home like
I told you I'm ordered to stay and help you now
you take these things of Becca where you found
them and then go home we've got to put a good
voice but you gotta put a bigger Nerva - come on
why they put you in there off on a place they took
me there with my mother died oh well will you get
that for so did your mama sing no you Papa maybe
you know what do you mean you don't know I don't
remember my father but I know a song he wrote
my mother taught it to me maybe he could sing
but make you ever some arms for uncle cause I
know what the no donation that's a fine you stay
that way never ever not relation but what's
your name anyway good could I stay with you
no what's the matter with you why you want to
stay with me I don't blame you but the why you
pick on me oh you don't like the way I sing oh
so you had a mint huh just after that I'm gonna
show you something you finish any oh come on
you know I know what's this thing you like her
now I assure you why you make a bigger mistake
then you betcha Leslie you Trovatore mariachi
you know I was a put a bigger fellow before
I lose my voice what happened well that's a
big long story one day divorces she wasn't mine
the next day she know she not my wife she's the
greater Rose of the Lamb she's a great singer
today and me I give her first a bigger chance
it was a little kid to them it's used to send yo
you teach me to sing you like you did you teach
sure and she'll learn quicker too I wonder why she
think I would jump us crawling she'd see him today
it's awesome give it a rest are gonna meet
our TSM dear G I think that's beautiful I
wish I could sing like that well maybe you
could how would you like me to teach you huh
well how do I do that no that's no good
you forget you gotta go home I tell you
what I do for you would you like to see the
show game of the night all right I fix your
stains of my guest and friend doctor night
after the show you gotta go home me minion
you're looking for something yes you're
with the show aren't you you bet we have
a where from the nape of Norfolk is asking
us to look up a runaway kid that hi little
boy brother of curly hairs have you seen it
sure I see it what where is he how I know I
saw a little boy like that team applet on we
come with too sure but I send them home but if
you run across him let us know you bet do we
know why not run away kids are on the show in
the right of the airport yeah kids or a new
lab will cost you a lot of trouble hey Joe
what I do with you if they catch you now then Oh
Joe tell them liar and maybe they put me in jail
I'll go back how you go you can do that it look
darker make my better color the police'll in the
back I'll tell you what I do let's see and maybe
I'd like to hear you sing one more time you come
along with to the next star then tomorrow morning
I figured out a good way to send you back to shore
hey that kid can sing at that
I've got my app Lisa we know
need a [ __ ] the horses we're
in a little room but now come on
on the with the other kinetic mechanism exsample
and now looking back in a book
now we'll never know the answers